You can do interesting
things with States.
So, here we have the, the Head Contour.
Another kind of model is,
suppose you've got some way
of detecting colored blobs that
represent say, Hands and Head.
Now your state would, might be the x,
y location of the hands and head.
And your measurement might be where
you think the colored blobs are, and
your sensor model might be how well
do predicted blobs match the color.
Your, you can use sort of any model you
want as long as you can have a state and
you can talk about how that
state expresses itself.
In fact, here's an even better model.
Suppose you want to track some region
of, of the distribution of colors.
Right?
So like maybe this region here or
this region here where you can see the
ellipse, that kind of gives away that
the region that we're going to,
we're going to be tracking here.
What would be a good model or
state for tracking that?
Okay.
Well, clearly you want the location,
because after all I want
to know where the thing is.
All right?
And if I've defined a region,
I want to know, sort of,
how that region is changing maybe
a little bit in orientation or size.
But just to tell me this, the position
and the size, that's not enough.
I need something about the appearance.
In this particular method, and
we're going to talk a lot
more about this next time.
What they tracked is really cool.
They tracked the distribution of colors.
Right?
So if I look over, let's say.
I'm not going to do that region,
I'm going to do this region over here.
All right.
There are some white pixels,
there are some reddish pixels,
there are some brownish pixels.
And as that player moves,
the shape will change in the form etc.
But the overall distribution of
colors might be quite similar.
All right?
And in fact what you
have to say is well,
what's a reasonable sensor model and
we're going to get to that next time.
But, basically what you're going to
do is you're going to compute
the similarity of the color
distribution of what you had, and
the color distribution
of your proposed state.
All right?
And
you'll need somewhere of comparing
those color distributions.
And just as a way of showing
you how well this thing works,
this, here's two examples.
This is actually done using mean-shift
filtering, but could also have
been done, using particle filtering, and
we'll talk about that, both, next time.